[Musique]
les 2 3 et 4 octobre prochains auront
lieu les troisièmes entretien du
patrimoine de l'océan indien au théâtre
du grand marché organisé par l'état et
l'école d'architecturé de la réunion cet
événement international a pour thème
patrimoine mise en valeur et
perspectives touristiques que ses
entretiens alors on plusieurs
objectivité de scander ainsi
régulièrement tous les trois ans des
rencontres avec des universitaires des
politiques des conservateurs sur le
terrain des associations venues de la
totalité des pays de l'océan indien
enfin ou pas la totalité mais enfin de
le plus possible cette année on a onze
donc de les réunir pour échanger des
expériences voir ce qui marche ce qui
marche pas nourrir des réseaux
propriétaires de nombreux équipements
culturels le conseil départemental est
cette année partenaire de l'événement
avec le conseil régional le rectorat de
l'académie de la réunion et l'île de la
réunion tourisme on est propriétaire
d'un patrimoine énorme au niveau du
département
on va citer le musée léon dierx le
lazaret numéro un numéro 2 le musée de
villèle donc on est concerné par cette
troisième édition du patrimoine de
l'océan indien
tous les pays de la zone vont participer
à ce colloque
et c'est tout à fait naturellement que
pour cette troisième édition le départ
le département soit présent et prenne
toute sa place
ces entretiens mettront l'accent sur le
patrimoine comme moteur du développement
économique et touristique
ils seront ouverts au public
[Musique]